tausende menschen sind derzeit in der
hauptstadt in berlin auf den straßen
unterwegs um gegen die korona maßnahmen
der bundesregierung zu demonstrieren
unsere reporter sind den ganzen tag für
sie vor ort am großen stern ist eine
abschlusskundgebung geplant und genau
dort wollen wir jetzt auch einmal
hinsehen
mein kollege til biermann ist dort vor
ort am großen stern
das soll es ja jetzt wie gesagt die
große kundgebung geben wie sieht es
jetzt im moment dort aus sind schon
viele menschen da es sind sehr viele
menschen da das sieht man auch diesem
bild ist leider nur ganz hinten da so
viele menschen da sind dass das internet
sonst nicht mehr funktioniert und ihr
mich nicht sehen könnten
dort gibt es verschiedene redner auf
einer rednerbühne die skurrilste
situation war wahrscheinlich als robert
kennedy das ist ein kennedy nachfahre
auftrat und er ist so etwas wie soll
eine galionsfigur der leute hier
er sagte dass jetzt die krone krise
genutzt werden würde um 5 g zu
installieren um die menschen zu
kontrollieren damit bill gates alle
menschen kontrollieren könne
und das ist eine sklaverei drohe und das
einzige was zwischen der menschheit und
der sklaverei noch stehe sind diese
demonstranten in berlin das hat den
leuten hier natürlich gefallen haben
geklatscht
ja es ist eine skurrile mischung hier
auf jeden fall sind sehr viele menschen
dort es wird immer wieder dazu
aufgerufen den abstand zu halten damit
die polizei die demo nicht auflöst genau
und das ist die lage
was genau soll dennoch am großen stern
passieren was ist für die kundgebung
noch geplant welche redner sind dort
jetzt eingeladen welche redner jetzt
genau noch kommen werden weiß ich jetzt
gerade nicht auf jeden fall ist es
möglich verschiedene leute war noch ein
redner so ein raichs bürger der sagte
dass er hoffe dass der friedensvertrag
bald neu verhandelt werden würde
die diese leute sind ja der meinung dass
deutschland kein rechtmäßiger staat sei
und deswegen gibt es ja auch viele
menschen mit reichs lagen dann war ein
skurriler redner dabei einer von denen
er sagt er sei von den grünen und da gab
es erst mal viel gebrüll weil er sagt er
sei von den grünen aber dann sagt er
halt halt er habe ja in seiner eigenen
partei
die maßnahmen stark kritisiert und habe
dafür viel kritik bekommen genau der hat
dann auch viel applaus bekommen
es gibt ja die leute hinter mir reden
immer noch ich höre mir das weiter an
und die menschen tatsächlich versuchen
auch dort jetzt die abstände einzuhalten
eben damit die polizei das ganze nicht
auflöst für wann ist denn die große
abschlusskundgebung geplant
das habe ich jetzt tatsächlich gar nicht
mitbekommt wir waren die große abschluss
demo geplant ist weiß auch so viele also
die taktik dieser leute scheint zu sein
auch viele verschiedene demos anzumelden
damit wenn eine eine aufgelöste wie
vorhin die an der friedrichstraße damit
sie dann weiterziehen können wir jetzt
an den großen stern
es ist gut möglich dass noch eine
weitere angemeldet wurde
wo man dann hinziehen könnte damit man
möglichst lange hier seinem recht auf
meinungsäusserung nachgehen kann
und genau da ist es schwer den überblick
gerade zu behalten ist entstehen auch
immer mehr splittergruppen ist in
verschiedenste veranstaltungen rund um
das brandenburger tor um den großen
stern und unter den linden jahr geplant
und sage uns einmal cdu ist jetzt auch
den ganzen tag für uns die situation
beobachten können es ist eine sehr
heterogene menschenmenge die dort
zusammen kommt kannst du jetzt wo es in
den abend geht veränderungen beobachten
wir hatten ja auch familien auf der
straße
es ist jetzt so dass sich die
demonstrations- menge ein bisschen auch
verändert so wie ich das beobachten
konnte also ich war bis vor 15 minuten
noch da hinten noch nicht es sind immer
noch familien da ist sind immer noch
menschen unterschiedlicher also aus ganz
deutschland da aus oldenburg ich hab mit
einem querdenker aus oldenburg
gesprochen
aus bayern aus ganz deutschland sind
gekommen
wenn man allerdings dann näher mit
entspricht so heterogenen was deren
meinungen angeht ist es gar nicht wenn
man ein bisschen nach port ja woran
liegt das denn alles mit diesem chor
oder maßnahmen die diese leute ja für
falsch halten kommt man schnell dann
dabei an dass bill gates die menschheit
vergiften möchte und die rothschilds
dahinter stecken würden also diese
verschwörungs mieten sind leider sehr
verbreitet tillmann am großen stern
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen wir werden das weiter
beobachten